mission impossible - I'm continuing in
my series of Mission Impossible reviews
leading up to Mission Impossible rogue
nation this July I've already covered
the very first Mission Impossible film
if you missed that that video is
currently on my channel right now but
let's talk about possibly the most
divisive movie in the entire franchise
and just as a warning just like the
first film this will contain spoilers
about plot details so if you haven't
seen Mission Impossible 2 yet go check
it out first then come back and watch
the review but more than likely you have
because it was like 15 years ago you
should probably get on that Tom Cruise
has stated that he wanted a different
director for each film in the franchise
that's a good idea for certain reasons
for one each time a director comes on
he's fresh he's new he's excited to
direct a Mission Impossible movie it
gives a different feel to each one
similar to the James Bond movies but
it's also a bit of an issue particularly
with this film because they hadn't yet
figured out what worked about the
franchise they were still in a sort of
experimental phase so we have here a
drastically different movie from the
first one which set a lot of people in a
bad mood the basic plot of mi-2 is that
a virus has been created called chimera
it's Ethan Hunt and his team's job to
find all traces of said virus and
eliminated but there's also a rogue
agent played by Dougray Scott who is out
to find this virus get rich off of it
and spread it throughout humanity
because he has the cure so if he gives
everyone this virus this cure is gonna
be worth a lot of money and these guys
butt heads and they fight and there is a
lot of slow-mo but the main emotional
punch of this movie is a romance between
Ethan Hunt and Naya and when he
discovers that she used to have a
romance with Sean Ambrose portrayed by
Dougray Scott she is forced to then go
undercover pretending that she needs him
to find out information about him you
can't really watch Mission Impossible 2
expecting a Mission Impossible movie
because what it really is is a big Hong
Kong martial arts movie with mission
impossible in the title now in all
honesty this is a gorgeously shot movie
it's a very breathtaking film there's
tons of great cinematography a lot of
really good action and it's all filmed
and choreographed very well but it gets
to a point of silliness from time to
time
because it takes itself way too
seriously but there were a lot of new
ideas brought forth in this movie that
just did not work at all for a Mission
Impossible movie this may have worked as
a straight-up action film directed by
John Woo but not as a Mission Impossible
movie if one of the biggest reasons as
they change Ethan hunts character way
too much in this film he's really like a
carefree playboy type James Bond
character in the first film he was a
very efficient person the mission was
always first he knew exactly what he was
doing he was also a bit of a man on the
run type character so there was a lot of
urgency there in this film he is way
more like James Bond he meets this girl
he sleeps with her he's rock climbing in
the beginning it's an iconic sequence
but why is he really risking his life
out there rock climbing what's the point
really of it besides to get some really
cool shots of Tom Cruise rock climbing
in fact the entire car chase scene were
Ethan Hunt and nya are chasing each
other along that stretch of road is
right out of Goldeneye this movie was
trying to be like a Bond film and it
just shouldn't have been these aren't
James Bond movies they're a very
different type of film and since mi-2
they've begun to recognize that need but
this film tried to make it too much like
a double-oh-seven movie and also with
the plot to try to get nya into Sean
Ambrose's life again it creates a love
triangle between them to anything hunt
who needs a love triangle in a Mission
Impossible movie no one now it's great
to see ving rhames back as luther
stickell he was one of my favorite parts
of the first film he was so funny he was
so likeable yet he was also a computer
nerd so it was such a cool character her
Ving Rhames to play in this film
they removed almost all of his humor
he's just there any types things where
the humor go he became such an
uninteresting character in this movie in
fact the pilot of the helicopter in this
movie adds absolutely nothing he's just
there to pilot a plane there's nothing
he adds nothing to this movie as a
character in all honesty John Woo the
director is the most prevalent character
in this movie the slo-mo the doves of
course he had to put all these doves
into the movie so we all knew we were
watching a John Woo movie the crash
zooms on people's faces do you have any
idea how many zooms on people's faces
are in this film tons I could show the
rest of this review it'd be nothing but
zooms on people's faces and this review
would be like an hour-long the
first film moved it was so fast-paced
this film takes forever to get anywhere
the first act has nothing of interest
it's just a whole bunch of discussions
about some disease that's been created
and a whole bunch of forced awkward
romantic scenes with Ambrose and Naya
that are just weird and they give you
goosebumps it's there's nothing about
this first act of the movie and even
into the second act that's really that
entertaining it's honestly an hour into
this film before we get a real action
scene up until then it's just a bunch of
strange goose-bumpy romantic encounters
no one's hunt finally breaks into the
bio site facility to destroy the remains
of this virus there's a lot of really
fun action throughout this scene even
though it is overly stylized but my
biggest problem with this scene is that
he takes so much time to destroy these
viruses he honestly does it slower than
any Nicolas winning reppin film you've
ever seen and I'm a fan of roughen okay
he's walking around the room like
holding these guns going G G I'm like
dude speed it up now once the bad guys
nya and hunt all converge on this
facility there's a lot of really good
tension leading up to her eventually
injecting herself with the remains of
the virus I was very into the scene it's
very well done it's emotional hans
zimmer score is great but then ethan
takes her blows up the bombs that he set
and escapes why didn't he just do that
before she injected herself that would
have made everything a lot easier
wouldn't it and I do love the sequence
for Ethan Hunt jumps out of the hole in
the wall with Hans Zimmer's beautiful
score in the background once we actually
get to the big finale it's just nice to
finally see some action happening in a
mission impossible' movie and there's
tons of it it's like John Woo was almost
making up for the fact that there was
barely none throughout the first hour of
this film Tom Cruise typically performs
virtually all of his stunts and he does
a magnificent job as usual he's
basically giving the perfect Solid Snake
audition here sneaking around through
this facility taking out guards stealth
it's awesome it's really well done and I
do love the scene where he tricks
ambrose by taking out Ambrose his
right-hand man then putting the Ethan
Hunt mask on him and forcing Ambrose to
killed his own right-hand man assuming
that's hunt it's a really well executed
scene and once we get to the big
motorcycle chase scene I mean watching
it now it all looks great
it doesn't look fake it actually looks
very realistic there isn't a single shot
throughout that scene that looks like it
didn't actually happen but it's kind of
stupid that as soon as this scene starts
he's laying on the ground and he's like
he reaches in his pocket he puts on some
sunglasses I was like wow the matrix
clearly came out the year previous which
it did and of course there's the epic
money shot through the fire on the
motorbike I mean just that's beautiful
it's a beautiful moment in cinema oh
mission impossible too and I love how
Ambrose and hunt just drive their
motorcycles towards each other than
collide bodies in midair it's so
hilarious and dumb it's so stupid and
idiotic but you know they jumped off
their bikes and collided in midair
you see that's the problem with Mission
Impossible 2 you have those awesome
moments where they're like that's
amazing and then it's so super serious
with this virus you just can't take it
seriously that fight is pretty badass
though it's well filmed it's brutal it
looks like real pain is going on and the
stunt with the knife Tom Cruise you
insane person the stunt with a knife and
the eye that's real guys from all
reports from the set that is real they
rigged a knife with a cable to stop it
at just the right second above Tom
Cruise is I a real knife a real one now
that's right drop fly I would much
rather climb on Burj Khalifa than have a
knife stop 2 centimeter way before my
eye I mean that's if it just slipped a
second
I mean Dougray Scott would be a murderer
Tom Cruise wouldn't have an eye anymore
and probably be dead I mean what for me
mi tu is a mixed bag Tom Cruise is great
as Ethan Hunt in the fight scenes and in
the stunt work but he's too much of a
James Bond type playboy character in the
script for this movie when there is
action it's very exciting and well
choreographed and well filmed but it's
way too overly stylized and the serious
romance and virus storyline just makes
the whole film feel very way down in Chi
depressing and I think John Woo was
thinking this movie looks so cool
everything is so cool but it's really
just too cool for its own good this
movie lost a lot of the tone of the
first film that urgency that real spy
like action the suspense the real human
characters this movie made those
characters kind of cartoony and weighed
way to stylized but the biggest plus of
this movie is that if this movie didn't
happen we would not have Hugh Jackman as
Wolverine why is that
well Dougray Scott was actually the
first person cast as Wolverine but had
to drop out due to his involvement with
mi-2
so Hugh Jackman got the part and thank
goodness for that I'm always trying to
look on the positive Thanks am i - I
appreciate that
all in all I'm going to give Mission
Impossible to a scene I can still watch
this movie for what it is like I can
have it on I can appreciate some of the
action scenes but the over serious tone
is just not the right style or feel for
a Mission Impossible movie and I think
if this movie wasn't called Mission
Impossible - if it was called like
slow-mo shots or something then it would
be perfect to be a great movie but not a
Mission Impossible movie guys thank you
so much as always for watching look
forward to my mi3 review which is going
to be coming up in the near future and
as always if you guys like this you can
click right here and get stuck mine eyes
Oh